بالجمهور كله حبها بده يسمعها في استديو
طبعا انا قلت لكم قبل هواء يعني الصوت
اليوم شويه رايح كان عندي حفله
امسحيه لكن ان شاء الله سمعكم بالصوت
المتبقي ههه اتفضل
مرحبا وسهلا كل من محله هذا العالم وسعبت
انا واحلى زينا المباني حققنا الاماني عيش
اللحظه معنا
الملعب جمعنا يلا غنوا معنا نغمه عربيه
[موسيقى]
وعلى الوعد جانا يلا نلعب سويا
اغنيه
وكمان ااا حمود كمان بنشير انه انتم عملته
على نسائها النسخه المغربيه ديمه مره
بعد نزول الاغنيه بكم اسبوع ومعانا نجاح
المنتخب المغربي اللي نحييه ونحيي كل
جمهور المغرب كنا راح رايحين مباراه
المغرب والبرتغال انا وزميل الفنان ماهر
زين اللي فازوا فيها وصلوا بعدها نصف
النهائي لقينا لازم نسوي شيء خاص للمنتخب
المغربي والجمهور المغرب فحولنا على نفس
اللحن كتبنا كلمات مع الشاعر سمير المجاري
من المغرب شاعر غنائي معروف كتبنا الكلمات
عملنا اغنيه ديمه مغرب على نفس الحنه